because the difference has turned out to
be greater than anything ever published.
So, I want to make sure to point out
this is not yet a peer-reviewed paper.
It will come out as a peer-reviewed p
paper later this year, but the results
are so striking that we want people to
be aware of them because there really is
something that can be done now for
cognitive decline as we've all been
seeing now for over 10 years. But this
was the best proof yet in the trial. So
let me start. Uh Kat, you are the
trialist among the group of the six
sites, the one who has the most
experience with trials and I know you've
conducted over the years something like
a hundred. Um tell me how many of the
trials that you've done in the past led
to cognitive improvement.
Well, some of them did. I did all of the
first generation of Alzheimer medication
trials before the new anti-analoid drugs
and some of them like Aerys did have
some improvement but it didn't last
beyond a year. So you could have you
know a mild improvement but it wasn't
sustained. And one of the thing and then
then I actually did a study with one of
the first anti-amaloid drugs years ago
and we showed that that drug could wipe
out the amaloid plaques but it did not
translate to clinical improvement. So
that drug never made it onto the market.
So um so yeah, this is quite exciting to
be involved in these two trials where we
don't just slow things down, but we
actually reverse what's happening by
addressing all of the underlying causes.
And that's that's the difference. I mean
maybe medications can reduce amaloid
plaques, but the process will keep going
if you don't deal with the underlying
drivers of the disease.
Yeah, you made an important point which
is sustainability. And so as you know
Dr. Schneider from USC has published a
paper saying what about the follow-ups
on people who went on Aeris and
unfortunately in the long run they did
worse than people who weren't treated at
all. So you're really essentially
pushing things up to the front. You're
frontloading but in the long run it's
actually hurting you unfortunately. On
the other hand you know we've published
a paper showing people who even over 10
years continue to have sustained
improvement. And so actually let me ask
you an in your patients who've been
treated for several years are you seeing
sustained improvements
in the patients who continue to follow
the protocol and not everyone does of
course
right
um but in the patients who continue to
follow the protocol we see sustained
improvement improvement that you know
not not just stabilizes but they
continue to improve you know not not
really my patient personally, but Judy
Benjamin is an incredible example of
that. You know, not part of the study,
but
just an amazing uh an amazing result.
We're seeing this again and again, and I
just got an email from one of the people
who's now been on eight years, and her
scores are still going up. Uh her latest
scores are better. Even though she was
into the normal years ago, she's
actually still getting better with her
scores. So, that's that's great to see.
So, let's talk about the the trial
that's just been completed. Uh we'll
have a paper coming out uh in the next
several months as I mentioned, but
meanwhile there is a free posted online
preprint that you can see that describes
all the details and summar summarizes uh
what we saw in this trial. So, this was
a randomized control trial. It was
carried out at six different sites
around um and you can see it on
clinicaltrials.gov.
So it is part of the the government
online description of trials. Um it it
was nine months. So people were
randomized either to group A which was
the precision medicine protocol or to
group B which was standard of care. And
essentially that meant going back to
their PCP or their neurologist and
having them do what they usually do,
which I think is actually a good idea
because we're all I think we've all been
impressed with the fact that there's not
a lot of treatment going on out there.
There is some aerosept being used often.
Um but in general, people aren't doing a
lot and they're telling people, well,
you're not that bad yet, you know, come
back later. That sort of thing. And I've
been horrified to see the sort of
treatment that people are getting. In
fact, our control group was very similar
to the control group that was in some of
the other trials that have been
published. So, I think it's good. It
helps us to match up with those trials.
Also the degree of impairment was
similar to other trials in that these
were people who had MCI was the MCI
stage or early dementia stage that is to
say mocha scores of 18 or higher but
with symptoms and with AQ21s. In other
words, their partners had noticed that
they were having problems as well. So
for multiple different uh different
analyses it was clear that there was
impairment going on from symptoms from
partners from their test scores all
those sorts of things. Uh and then these
were people who were treated for nine
months and then looking at during that
time what happened to their cognition,
what happened to their epigenetics, what
happened to their biochemistry, what
happened to their physiology, all these
sorts of things. Uh and so when we look
at the end here, the striking thing was
that the difference between the group
that was in the control group that
continue to go downhill with their
memory, downhill with their overall
cognitive scores versus the ones treated
by Dr. Hathaway, Dr. Tups, um and the
other four physicians um that I'll
mention here, Dr. Craig Tanio, uh Dr.
Christine Burke, Dr. Nate Bergman, Dr.
David Hos uh all together those six
sites um as an average they went up up
up uh through the nine months. Very
striking. So they had improvements in
their overall cognition. They had
improvements in their composite memory
scores. They had improvements in their
executive function. They had
improvements in their processing speed.
Really striking. They had improvements
in their symptoms. Their partners
noticed the improvement. This wasn't one
of these things where it was so small
that the partners didn't even notice it,
which has happened in other trials in
the past. These were clearly noticeable
by the partners. So, by all criteria,
these people were clearly better. Now,
some much better, some a little better,
but by all criteria, they were better.
So, I think it's helpful sometimes to
have an illustrative case or two. Um,
Kat, can you mention I know you you in
your I should mention in all your group,
every single treated patient got better.
That's unheard of in the Alzheimer's
field. So, congratulations for that. Can
you mention just one case as an example?
Sure. And and let me say with every
every patient getting better, um, all
but one of my patients tested in a
completely normal range by the end of
the study. And I had people that started
with mild Alzheimer's and then you know
some with MCI but you know even those
down to most of 20 21. So we had people
coming from a place of very clear
impairment into complete normalization.
Now do they have further to go? Sure. As
as uh Ann mentioned you know people can
still keep getting better and better.
And one thing I wanted to say was by
doing the full court press we worked
fast and furious because we only had
nine months to move the needle. But what
I saw in my cohort is a lot of people by
three months had already made phenomenal
gains. And so, you know, if you if
you're working with everything at once,
which is what we did, um, and give
people the proper support, they can
shift so quickly. So um I and my one
patient that didn't test completely
normal I would mention was still working
on resolving mold issues in her home
which we know is a neurotoxin and causes
degeneration in the brain but she
doubled her scores on her CNS vital
signs neuroscychiatric battery. So she
was still clearly improving. Um, I have
one patient that is is such an
interesting story because, um, not only
did everything normalize for him
cognitively. I mean, he scored a perfect
score on his mocha at one point, but it
also, um, resolved all of his medical
and physical issues as well. This
gentleman was scheduled to have three
different joint replacements. He told me
he could barely get up the stairs. He
had to walk sideways and hold on because
he had so much pain. Guess what? All
those joints are normal now. He has no
more pain. He doesn't need surgeries,
joint replacement surgeries. What a a
wonderful um side effect of our study.
He also had autoimmune disease. He had
my gravis which is a pretty serious
autoimmune disease and basically we
resolved all the symptoms of those and I
was watching his antibbody levels come
down um because of the treatment. Um, I
believe we uh, you know, got them off of
blood pressure medicines. And so, you
know, the exciting thing is not only
what we're doing is is turning around
the cognition and helping people, you
know, to to reclaim their their brain
and their cognitive function, but it
helps everything else because, of
course, that's the whole premise of what
we do, right? Everything's connected.
The brain is connected to the body. So,
as we address all of these drivers, they
all help the brain and vice versa. Yeah,
you know, you brought up a really good
point, which is that people get better
not just cognitively, but actually in
the trial, we saw improved statistically
significant improvements in systolic
blood pressure, in diastolic blood
pressure, in BMI, in homocyine,
in hemoglobin A1C, in lipid profiles. So
again and again and again we're seeing
this improvement not just in the brain
but also in physiology. It's really
striking to see. Um Dr. Hathaway could
you mention one of the patients who came
through just an illustrative case um and
what you saw.
Yeah. Um, enthusiasm counts for a lot
and all my patients were enthusiastic
because we we look for that in in our
selection, but uh my patients who were
the most enthusiastic uh did the best.
Uh my patient who lost 35 lbs, she got
her ketones. Ketones was one of our uh
one of the things that we asked people
to do to get uh into ketosis,
meaning a ketone level between 1 and
four. This woman's ketones were 3.5 to
four within a month of starting the
protocol. She just she she just was um
well, like I said, I think she was
probably gifted in ketosis in some way.
Some people struggle with that. Some
people struggle with getting their
glucose down. For some people, it's it's
it's easy. Uh so each each individual
each individual is is their own
interesting challenge. But uh
uh this particular
woman who's an ApoE4, by the way, uh a
homozygous for a4, she um lost, like I
said, 35 pounds. She got rid of all of
her joint pain, muscle aches, etc. that
were keeping her from being able to
exercise. She was enthusiastic about all
aspects of exercise including the
highintensity interval
kind of exercise which is which is quite
quite demanding. Um after she lost she
quickly lost uh 20 pounds and then the
other 15 came off slowly. uh she and her
scores were just I I don't remember her
exact scores. I wish I could tell you
but her scores were were dramatically
improved within 3 months and of course
by 9 months they were they were really
excellent. Uh she she was able to during
the study which I did not encourage
during the study she decided she was
going to become a health coach and took
a health coaching course.
Yeah.
She she was just amazing. Yeah.
Yeah. you know, one of the earliest
patients I had uh wrote back and said,
you know, I have a new life now and um
she started her new nonprofit. She went
back to school. She just said, "Look,
this is my new life now. I'm going to do
all these things that I wasn't able to
do before." So, it's great to see. So
you mentioned the scores and I think you
know there's a huge amount of data which
is going to be one of the I think best
outcomes from this that we'll be able to
look at the epigenetics and and we'll be
able to look at the imaging and we'll be
able to look at all the different pieces
all the biochemistry etc all the and the
biomarkers of course these are all
critical but one of the points I wanted
to mention is that as you can imagine
when these people started their average
scores for their cognition were of
course below average. So if you're
looking at average for their age, most
of the people that are making up the
average don't have cognitive decline. So
of course they were below that. But
interestingly, at the conclusion, the
ones who were treated were actually
above the average, above the 50th
percentile for people their age. That's
50th percentile for people who are not
cognitively affected. just as Cat said a
few minutes ago, her patients ended up
being in the normal range for their
cognition, which again is unheard of
with these sorts of treatments. So that
was uh very very exciting to see. And of
course, the ones who were in the control
group started out below average and went
further downhill during that time. Um
that brings up another key point here,
which is the bounce. So the people who
were in the control group but then after
9 months they were offered six months of
free treatment so that they could get
the benefit and we have just one uh so
far just one site uh Dr. Craig Tanio
who's reported his what happened before
and you could see a beautiful they went
down then they went up strikingly but
Kat you made a really good point the
other day which is that even waiting
that nine months is not a good idea for
these people because it makes it
tougher. They're continuing that process
and maybe if you could say something
about your patients who were in group B
the control but then switched over at
the end of the nine months and began the
treatment. What happened to them?
Yeah. So my personal feeling is for
starters we have showed you tremendous
benefit in all measures of cognition
with this study and so we know this
works and I feel like the need to have a
control group in the future should be
done away with because I watched my
patients decline that were not getting
active treatment and then once they
rolled over into the active treatment
they did not improve as quickly.
as my patients that I had gotten earlier
in the process. So, I feel like, you
know, the longer you wait while your
brain is degenerating, the harder it's
going to be to turn that ship around,
you know. So, so they did improve.
Absolutely. But, um, it wasn't as
rapidly as the patients did in the other
treatment group. It's a really good
point and it really brings up the issue
of ethics in standard control groups in
in standard of care treatment control
groups. And so I wonder whether there
will end up being more use of historical
controls because the historical controls
you could see that you know they clearly
went downhill. there's less of that as
people are catching on and people are
trying to do some of the things
themselves and so the control groups
tend to do a little bit better even
though we saw that there was some
decline overall they tend to do a little
bit better than control groups from say
20 30 years ago so people are kind of
catching on to this uh and what in your
I know you're you're an expert in BHRT
uh in bio identical hormone replacement
how many of your patients ended up being
treated that included bio identical
hormones.
Well, every woman who was in my study
was treated with BHIP
and of course, you know, I I certainly
have spoken at great length in many uh
in many different venues about the uh
incredible power of uh estradile for
brain health uh for cardiovascular
health and for bone health. Uh and
fortunately at this particular point in
time uh menopausal hormone replacement
is having a moment. Uh there's a lot
more positive being written about it.
They've talked about it. There's
multiple books. you know the physicians,
the women physicians who are uh you know
the the number of women physicians has
expanded tremendously and that group of
women that that wave of women physicians
is reaching their mid-40s now and they
are all like we are not going to be
putting up with no hormone replacement.
We are going to be getting our our
hormones and it's very important. I
mean, there's so much that I could talk
about that for two hours, but the the
importance of using the right hormone,
topical estradiol that's biioidentical
and real progesterone is extremely
important and also replacing
testosterone at a low dose for women is
also important. All of those things make
a huge difference uh in terms of overall
health and in terms of cognitive health.
Yeah. And of course, the issue often
comes up about age. In this trial,
people were from 45 to 76. I can't
remember if the highest one was 76 or
77, but it was one of those two. Uh and
and the average age in this trial was
65. So, it was actually fairly similar.
Now, we've all seen younger people. When
I was training way back in the 1980s at
UCSF, we never saw people in their 40s
and 50s with Alzheimer's disease. It's a
relatively common thing to see now. Uh
so things have changed along the way. Um
but in this particular case, the average
age was 65. There were 50 patients who
were in the treated group and there were
23 who were in the control group. It was
originally meant to be 2:1. We got a
couple of extras in the treatment. One
we had a dropout uh in the other group.
So uh some people would say, well, why
wasn't it a thousand people? So here's
why.
When you have something that has a tiny
tiny effect, you have to have a thousand
or more patients because you won't have
a statistically significant difference.
So we started by calculating what is it
going to take to see a statistically
significant difference and the answer
was between 50 and 60 people. So we
ended up with 73. We wanted to go a
little bit beyond that to make sure that
we had that. The other factor here is
this trial cost $6.6 6 million and we
are truly grateful to Diana Mariam and
the four winds foundation for the
support of the trial. Other trials if
you do a thousand people that will be an
$80 million trial. There is actually one
uh one treatment where now the trial
costs have exceeded a billion.
Hard to believe but there it does cost a
lot of money to do these trials as you
can imagine. And we, you know, you're
generating large amount of data. You've
got a lot of people involved. Uh, as we
were going through this preprint,
looking at all the acknowledgements and
all the co-authors, you know, I realized
how what a huge effort this this really
does take a village. It really is a huge
huge effort for years and thousands of
hours on a lot of people's parts. So,
yes, great to do one for a,000. Um, you
know, if we come up with $80 million to
do that, that would be a consideration.
But the key here, and this is why the
statistics are so important, is to do
enough people to see if there's a
statistically significant difference.
And the answer is it's a huge
difference. And in fact, the statistics
were not at the 0.05 level, which is the
standard accepted. Most of these
differences were less than 0.0001.
So a very high degree of significance
for most of these uh trials. The
processing speed was 0.01. So one out of
a 100. So really striking striking
differences.
And Dale, excuse me. I think it's
important to note that this is
replicating our previous proof of
concept, right? So this isn't a flash in
the pan. This is replicating the results
that we had in the first trial. And
we've done even better in the responses
in this trial than we did in the first
trial, which already was exciting news
that 84% of our patients got better. So
now we're seeing even in some of the
sites like mine, 100% of people had
improvements. So um I think that's an
important thing to note.
Yeah, that's a great point. Uh so now
you know the the evidence if you take
all the evidence together there's a lot
of anecdotal evidence multiple published
um hundreds and hundreds of patients
people are seeing this time and time
again um then we have the trial that you
mentioned the proof of concept trial
where people the majority of people
improve then there was a replication of
that independently by Dr. Heather
Sanderson and her group that saw
virtually identical results and now we
have a randomized controlled trial. So,
you know, anyone can say I don't believe
it. Um, but in fact, it's it is
sometimes hard to believe because it's
so much better outcomes than have been
seen in the past. But it fits very much
with what people are seeing every day.
And we're now seeing also what it takes
to get that. So let's talk about that
for a moment because we see that the low
compliance just as Dean Orish has had
noted years ago with his cardiovascular
work. Less compliance, less outcome, no
big surprise. Better compliance, better
outcome. But Ann, you mentioned a few
years ago, you know, the compliance is
not easy. You're you're doing something,
but yet you've been able to put together
a really fantastic team. So an what do
you say to people to get the good
compliance that you and your team get?
Well, you have to work with these each
individual. By the way, I I do want to
mention that I did not do this alone
with my group. I had a phenomenal uh
nutritionist, Kia Sanford, a phenomenal
health coach, Lynn K Phillips, and uh my
Stacy Hawkins, my uh site coordinator,
just phenomenal at their jobs. And so we
uh worked with these people uh in the
study who were already, you know, chosen
because they were on board. they really
wanted to to do it. Um, but we had very
close communication
between all of us as a team. When
someone picked up, okay, some someone's
fallen off here or there, we were on
them immediately to help them correct
course and get back into whatever
whatever was the problem. you know,
someone, you know, people developed um
people fell and they had to see a a
physical therapist uh and a massage
therapist. And so, we would facilitate
things like that to make sure that um we
kept them as active as possible, as on
track as possible with we we tracked so
many things uh as a group. We tracked
how much sleep they got, how much deep
sleep, how much REM sleep, uh heart rate
overnight, uh oxygen level overnight,
etc. Um just as just as one example, you
know, we we tracked their their diet
very
Kia tracked their diet extremely closely
knowing, you know, why they were missing
ketosis that day because they had all
their they had their entire diet written
down.
our exercise code
right we used chronometer
that our nutritionists were able to
literally get the information online we
used a lot of different wearables and
trackers in the study
yeah or ring was very helpful
um and heart math was very helpful for
stress reduction
um heart math has been was helpful in
our first study helpful in this study
we're we're very grateful grateful to
them. Um and um
ketosis was measured by a ketone a blood
ketone meter on a regular basis. So
there were a lot there was a lot of work
and a lot of coordination between all
the people on each of our teams to get
this to get this to work. And uh some
might say, well, wasn't that extremely
expensive? And you know, our our answer
is uh well, yes, it's it's it's
expensive, but uh what's the cost of uh
memory care, assisted living uh for a
year once someone has dementia?
uh it's a lot more than uh the cost of
treating a patient in the early stages
of uh mild cognitive impairment, early
dementia
compared to five years in uh you know
memory care.
Absolutely.
Well, the thing with the coaching is you
need the coaching to help get started
and and get this program assimilated
into your life, but you don't need it
forever. That's not a forever cost. But
we definitely learned from the first
study that having the coaching and the
support, nutrition support, exercise
support, um diet, um uh just to help
with integrating all the aspects of the
protocol that helps people to shift very
quickly. So um like in the first study,
this study, every patient was assigned a
nutritionist, a health coach, and an
exercise coach. The exercise coaches
were amazing and and I had people that
never exercised a day in their life turn
into regular exercisers because we did
require that they exercise six days a
week in this protocol and we tracked it.
So um you know patients had to be
motivated to be in the study because
they had to have a certain level of
compliance with every aspect of the of
the protocol and if they were
non-compliant we had to discharge them
from the study. So that did help the
motivation for people. But I I hope that
that everybody else will be motivated by
the results that we got to institute
their own programs if they're having
problems because uh it just made a huge
difference.
Yeah. I mean this really has told us we
have to change
to recognize that you know this
something can be done. This is now
really the first effective approach to
cognitive decline. Please don't wait.
you know, people should get evaluated,
get on active prevention or early
treatment because there's so much that
can be done. And Kat, if you could say
something, I know in the first trial you
had a support group and it's been
pointed out that support groups tend to
help with getting even better outcomes.
So, we can continue now to see what are
the things that you add on to get better
and better outcomes. If you could talk
about a little bit about your support
group.
Yeah, right. We in the current trial we
had a support group and um my health
coach and nutritionist facilitated the
support group. They met monthly. Um this
was for the patients in the active
treatment of course and then once the
patients that were in the delayed
treatment um crossed over into active
treatment, they were able to join the
group as well. People found that
immensely supportive. um people that
were further along in the program were
able to help people that were just
coming to it to let them know that oh
maybe they struggled with ketosis or
exercise or brain training. But um
definitely that support of the patients
I think probably was a factor of why my
patients did well. Um so they really
enjoyed that and we've just um secured
funding that we're going to be able to
continue that support group for our
patients to stay the course. Right. So
um so we'll probably be starting that
next month. But both the patients and
their study partner who was usually the
spouse. So patients had to have a study
partner to come into this trial for two
reasons. One we validated that they had
impairments in all these different
areas. And so the study partner had to
also with the rating scale, you know, um
show us that that this patient was truly
um struggling in certain areas of their
life and their memory. Um so um so the
study partners were needed for the
rating scales, but they were needed to
support their loved one to help
implement this program daytoday as well.
So both the patients and their study
partners came to the support group.
Great. And an could you speak to the
issue that comes up often which is okay
this is great for the few people that
that will you will want to do this but
if you have you know a hundred people
who come to you on a you know just a
day-to-day basis what percentage your
just your guess what percentage are
appropriate for getting into your
protocol versus those that just say you
know I I'm just not going to be able to
do this.
Um well the ones who end up talking to
me in general are those who are
interested. So yes I have you know uh
for people who come in who make who who
take the time to think about it make an
appointment come in to get help with
their diminishing cognition
I would say 95%
decide to uh at least go ahead and try
the protocol and I would say 90%
continue.
Yeah. Fantastic. because of course we
want to make this available to everyone
possible and as you indicated look it's
far less in terms of cost than going to
a memory care facility and it's far less
in cost actually than other therapeutic
options um that are that are out there.
So in fact there there are some real
advantage and of course it's also more
effective and fewer side effects and
improving your overall health. So, it
it's kind of a no-brainer that it's
actually the the best thing going here
for for many reasons. Uh we've got uh
we've got some excellent questions here.
So, let's let's start to go through some
of these questions because there are so
many good ones. Uh first one here is
what's the best way to get started.
There are a couple of ways. Uh one thing
is just to go on my cqest.com.
It's a free cognitive test and you can
go from there because it does sneak up
on you. There are a lot of people that
think, well, I'm here. I'm really not
having problems. and they'll find out
no, they really are. The other
possibility, take a look at the
preprint. You'll see the six sites where
this was done and contact one of the
physicians like Dr. Hathaway or Dr. Tops
or Dr. Tanio or Dr. Bergman or one of
those people um and talk to them about
uh you know whe what they're doing at
the time, whether they're taking new
patients etc. Um John here says what
were the size of the group? So 50 in the
treatment group, 23 in the control
group. Next one here is uh Buck
Institute had a trial about achieving
ketosis. Uh yeah and and uh the the
conceptual nature the looking at the
inflammatory piece and the looking at
the toxicity and looking at energetics
mitochondrial support what molecules
interact with a itself a remarkable look
it's essentially
that's amaloid precursor protein not
everybody thank you I was gonna say that
amaloid precursor protein is a is a
receptor that sits in your neurons
especially near synapses And it
literally is a switch that's looking are
you going toward connection? Are you
going toward protection? So when when
things are bad, you go toward protection
and makes the amaloid which is an
antimicrobial which kills herpes and
kills various fungi and kills various
bacteria. When things are good, you're
making something called SAP alpha,
soluble AP alpha. That's building new
synapses. That's connection. So you got
connection protection. all these people
that we're seeing are on the protection
side. We got to get them back over. We
got to get rid of the things that are
causing that. So, the Buck Institute is
where the a lot of the conceptual nature
of this came from. And of course, Dr.
Hathaway uh and and Dr. Tubes are
experts in functional medicine, which is
the translational piece of this. How do
you actually tell what's going on and
and what to address? I think that's
where we're headed. Now, as far as this
particular trial you mentioned, which is
for ketones only, you know, in general,
we haven't found that single items are
that beneficial as much as an overall
precision medicine protocol. However,
I'm interested in the results of the
trial. We'll see. Um, it's important to
point out though that whether or not any
specific thing helped, it still may be
part of an overall optimal protocol.
That's that's the change in thinking
that we all have to undergo. Dale, can I
say something about in our trial? So,
um, the requirement in our trial was
that people achieve ketone levels of one
to four, so kind of mild to moderate
ketosis. And Dr. Hathaway mentioned her
patient that went almost up to four very
quickly. Most people don't do that. Um,
but what we observed in the first trial
was sometimes when people did go deeper
into ketosis, they had additional
benefits. Some people's brains light up
with ketosis and other people don't
notice as much. So, it's not a
one-sizefits-all necessarily for
everyone, but for the purposes of a
study, we had to standardize what what
people were doing with the diet. And I
have to say uniformly, I did exit
interviews with a lot of my patients and
they would all say they had so much more
energy. Their energy was um steady
throughout the day. they didn't crave
sugar, you know, so people all, you
know, it's a shift for some people to
really shift into ketosis if they're
eating a lot of carbs in their diet, but
but uniformly people appreciated the
benefits of the ketosis.
It's a great point. And as a
neurologist, you know, we would look for
to say that someone had Alzheimer's, we
would look for a PET scan that showed
reduced glucose utilization in the
temporal and parietal loes. And so yes,
you are in you are improving that by
getting those ketones because now not
only do they have the glucose which
they're not utilizing well enough, but
they've also they're getting better
insulin sensitivity. So now the glucose
is working better. Now they're getting
the ketones as well. So they're becoming
metabolically flexible. It's like a
Prius that's run out of both fuels and
now you got both fuels working again,
which is why you see these tremendous
improvements. So yeah, absolutely.
tremendous weight loss in some of our
patients that needed to lose weight. And
of course, we found ways to support the
people that were already thin and didn't
need to lose weight, you know, with
additional protein and collagen and, you
know, things like that. But, um, but the
tremendous weight loss for some of our
patient and you mentioned 35 pounds, the
gentleman that I spoke of that needed
the three joint replacements lost 35
pounds as well, which helped.
Interestingly, we had uh diagnosed his
sleep apnoa and then the sleep apnnea
got much better of course once he lost
the 35 pounds. So um so yeah the ketosis
part has has been an interesting thing
for both of our protocols.
But you brought up a really good point
which is there is a difference between
the person who comes in and wants to
lose some weight and is does have some
some extra atapost to lose versus the
ones who are frail. there are people who
are frail uh and so there is a
difference there in the way you treat
them to get the best outcomes. I would
also mention the the APOE4 group is
interested to say well wait a minute
about half of the people that we had in
this trial were APOE4 positive. There
were six that were APOE4 homozygous. Um
and then the rest of the half was uh was
hetererozygous. Um and you the question
was well did they do better or worse
than the other? In our earlier trial we
we did look at that and it turns out
that they both had statistically
significant improvements. Um so we and
we do see on a daily basis people who
are ApoE4 uh do very well on this
protocol as well as other but we'll see
we those are data we have not crunched
yet so there is tons of stuff still to
look at I'm interested particularly in
the correlations the people who got
metabolic improvements are they the ones
that got the best cognitive improvements
or not we have looked at the biioarkers
and so we looked at a beta 42 to40 ratio
GFAP P NFL and PTA 217
and let's say the A beta that he's
talking about that's the amaloid levels.
Great point. Yeah. So that's the amaloid
ratios. So what was interesting was the
GFAP which is the one that that that
reflects the ongoing inflammation in the
brain.
Wait and say that's gal fibrillary
acidic protein because these are
concepts for a lot of people.
Yeah, great great point. So yes, gal. So
what this is actually it's a protein
that is in your aststerytes not the
neurons and what happens is as your
astroytes are responding they're
responding with inflammation and they're
responding with attempted repair they
will actually get bigger and there so
they make this protein which is an
intermediate filament protein in the
astroite. you see as the aststerite
balloons up and is now getting it's
telling you you got active aststerytes
in your brain because of inflammation
and attempted repair. So the good news
is it was statistically significantly
improved in the treatment group and not
in the other group. But with PAL what we
found was something interesting and now
others are seeing the same thing but
initially we were not aware of this.
When you lose weight your pal goes up
without any change in your brain. you
just see a pa when your when your weight
goes up your pa is low. So you can
imagine there were people where they
would lose a lot of weight. They would
do much better cognitively but their pal
would actually shoot up as if they were
having more problem. Now over the nine
months they start to come down again.
And so it did turn out that there was
just barely significant an improvement
in pa but it wasn't impressive. And I
think that's partly because a lot of
people in group A lost weight whereas we
know that people in group B did not. In
fact, they gained a little bit of weight
um on the group B side. So I think that
there's a bit of a compromise there in
the PAL.
Well, we might need to analyze that
separately. It just occurred to me that
we should look at the people who didn't
gain weight, I mean didn't lose weight
versus the people that lost weight and
then see if we see a different signal
there. I think one other interesting
thing Dale was about the amaloid that um
you know we found that all but two of
the patients were positive with the
levels of amaloid which was pretty
interesting.
The vast majority of these people had
had the am the the amaloid related
Alzheimer process occurring in their
brain. Now that doesn't say that they
didn't have some louisi bodies there. uh
about 60% of people who end up with
Alzheimer's at autopsy will have some
louisi bodies as well. So there can be
multiple processes as we're
understanding these much more from the
physiological side instead of the
pathological side. Oh, you know there's
some bad stuff get rid of it. No, why is
it there? As we're understanding that we
we now are beginning to understand that
there are certain pathogens that are
targeted by amalloid and certain
pathogens that are targeted by
alphasuclean. So for example,
alphasuclean tends to be good at killing
E.coli. It tends to be good at killing
staff orius. Uh amalloid beta tends to
be good at killing herpes simplex. So
this is beginning to tell us what's
going on in the brain. And it's not so
surprising that in fact that you'll
often have these multiple things. You
have the PTA, you have the amaloid, you
have the alphasuclean, and you also have
the TDP43 which is another response like
amaloid. And TDP43 tends to be something
that responds to viruses that get into
your cells. So we're now beginning to
understand this whole process more from
the physiological response side than
from this old idea of there's something
bad, get rid of it.
Segue the test. I mean, this was
important because because what you're
hearing is we have these markers that
are, you know, of things accumulating in
the brain with Alzheimer's and
neurodeenerative processes. But the
thinking now is that they are
antimicrobial. So they they can they can
happen in response to toxins but also
infections. So one of the things that we
did in this study is we tested a whole
battery of infections. And these become
our treatment targets when they're
positive is to to help um to work to
reduce the burden of all these
infections in people. And for those
people who know that um HSV1 herpes
simplex virus type one is associated
with an increased risk of Alzheimer's
disease. Uh it makes sense that bec if
you have untreated
uh high HSV1 in your body and in your
brain your body's then going to make
more amaloid which then is going to go
ahead and start do more destruction in
your brain. So that's we treated many
viruses but especially we look for HSV1
and and treat that.
And of course now we just found out in
the last year right that there's a huge
correlation with multiple sclerosis with
other immune disorders because of the of
the viruses but it's always been part of
our paradigm with the treatments that we
do. Tests for these infections support
the immune system because when you have
viruses they activate the immune system
and then immune problems release all
kinds of inflammatory chemicals that can
you know further the neurodeeneration.
So I think one question Dale that I can
imagine people are saying well what do
we do about the herpes since that is
such a big big thing and I would say
most of us treated our patients with um
with valicyclo
which is a wellknown antiviral approved
for long-term use with herpes. So we did
um treat with that and then follow their
um antibbody their tighter levels of the
herpes and um you know we still don't
really know how long you need to treat
that that uh that's still being learned
about but um that is something we did I
think pretty much all the investigators
used bell cycle there for herpes
and this comes right back to the idea of
a comprehensive protocol as you know a
paper just recently appeared showing
that if you just treat you just take
people with Alzheimer's and you just
treat them with valet cyclloe. The hope
was oh it's going to go away. No, they
actually did worse than control if you
just used that alone. And I suspect
that's because now you're getting in and
you're creating more inflammation as
they're trying to mop this stuff up. So,
you know what? You've got to do the
whole thing. You've got to use it all
together as a precision medicine or
functional medicine or systems medicine
approach. We've got a lot of good
questions here and I know we're running
out of time. So, let's go through some
more of these questions. So, one was
when testing for lime, the
pre-publication said you used what
specific panel or tests did you test
for?
Um we uh tested the uh lime immunolot
for both borellia which is a classic
lime as well as burellia miamotoy which
is um relapsing tick fever that is
common in some of our areas like here in
California. So we tested amino for
those. We tested the fish test um
fluorescent immunino hybridization
something or other forum besia and
bartinella and um those were the main
panels that we did with ienics. The rest
of the co- infections like anoplasma or
lichia we used or labcore testing that's
at quest and labcore. Um and then all
the viruses that we tested were also
through lab core. We tested herpes, we
tested cytogalo virus, myopplasma,
toxoplasmos, toxoplasma.
Um I'm probably
HSV6
HHV6.
Yes. Um so
anoplasma Ioplasma.
Yeah. So yeah, so a lot of these tests
we were able to get through commercially
available, you know, lab companies that
and and I'll just say one trick for
clinicians that are listening. Um
because I I can get, you know, most of
this stuff covered to people's
insurance, but I always put 10 diagnosis
codes. So I try to tell the story of why
I need all these tests and uh and they
generally can can get covered in the
workup for people.
Yeah. Igenics uh accepts Medicare.
They accept Medicare and they added one
commercial insurer. I mean it's a
barrier with hygienics because it's
expensive
and so you know it is difficult for
people to get the proper testing there.
But yes for Medicare again with the
proper diagnosis codes you can get
testing covered on Medicare but as as
you know we heard we're seeing people
earlier and earlier with with cognitive
decline and so they don't all have
Medicare.
Yeah. There's a question here from an
about NeuroQ. Um, and full disclosure, I
was involved in creating it. So, please
understand that. All I can say, it's got
six different components in it. It
addresses some of the things we've
talked about, but supplements are
supplementary. I think that's the most
important point to realize. All
supplements are supplementary. You've
got to get at the fundamentals. The
great news is we now have we now have a
foundation. So, we can now begin to add
what happens if you add stem cells. What
happens if you add intraasal peptides?
What happens if you add these things?
We've got a foundation that we know and
we've proved works. Uh question here
about Louisibody disease. This is a
great question. Louibody disease is a
close cousin of both Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's. You have the alpha suclean
that you make in Parkinson's, but you
have the cognitive change that is very
similar to Alzheimer's with some some
differences often with some visual
hallucinations and things like that. So
when and we do see people on this
protocol do well with Louisibody
disease, but you really have to focus in
on the toxic part. Cat was just talking
about toxins and how important it is to
look for these. They kind of three
different types. The inorganics, uh,
things like air pollution and mercury,
the organics, things like tuine and
benzene and and microlastics and
anesthetic agents. And then it's the
biotoxins, the things like triccoins and
okrtoxin A and things like that. And by
the way,
translate he's talking about mold.
Yeah, mold related toxins. And this
OTAA, the okra toxin A is actually one
that specifically damages the
hippocample neurons. So that's a
particularly important one. Uh so yeah,
so that that's the situation. Please, if
you're dealing with Louis body disease,
make sure to see someone who is really
good with dealing with toxins like Dr.
Hathaway or Dr. Tubes. Let's say what we
we did as far as the testing for toxins.
So, we did um panels um with real-time
labs for chemical toxins and we also did
a panel with them for micotoxins. In our
first study, we used what's now Mosaic
Labs. It was Great Plain Labs. Um, so
they also do testing for both of these.
And they did not have both panels
available at the time we started the
study. But both of those companies will
do panels for both micotoxins and
chemical toxins. And then we tested
heavy metals through LabCore. So Quest
and Labcore. And you can get blood
levels of, you know, mercury and cadmium
and lead and arsenic, which is what we
did. And I would just say a caveat again
to the clinicians. If you're testing for
mercury, I I know I use Quest and I have
to order the mercury quantitative so
that I get an actual number. Otherwise,
and if you ordered the whole panel, they
just report less than four. Well, okay.
I get worried if the mercury is getting
at one and above. You know, I don't want
to wait until it's already at four
before I'm going to initiate some
strategies like seafood avoidance and
sulfor detox the mercury
and labor does give a panel with uh
cadmium mercury, lead and arsenic. And
do they give the actual
give the actual number? And also we got
uh our metals tested by Great Plains on
the Neutra Val in the study.
Nice. Okay. Next one here is uh this is
for you Cat because I know you deal with
a lot of POTS. So this is a person who
has POTS and has brain fog and mild
memory loss. Um and the pharmacist told
him AISEP was contraindicated. He's
already being treated for tacoc cardia
and POTS. What about medications? Um,
again, this is something you're dealing
with a lot.
Well, you know, the POTS is again
another multiffactorial thing. Well,
we've seen a huge epidemic with COVID. I
know I developed POTS after the first
CO. So, I I'm very empathetic with that.
Um, uh, so like all things, you've got
to kind of address everything. What's
the inflammation? What's the toxin
burden? What's the um um, you know,
burden of um of infections kind of
thing. But um so there's not a single
thing that's going to help mitigate the
POTS. But one thing that I will say um
from already doing all those things in
myself was um oxytocin was personally
helpful for me with POTS and you know
oxytocin is a hormone uh they call it
the love hormone or the bonding hormone
but um there is some data with POTS and
um it has to be ordered through a
compounding pharmacy. I use Belmar
Pharmacy for mine, but um but I have to
say that personally for me was a help.
So, I'll just throw that out there.
That's a sample of one, but I tried it
because of some data I found showing
that it could be helpful for for POTS.
Great. Then there's one question here
about what percentage of the people
needed treatment beyond lifestyle such
as detox, gut, infection treatment, etc.
I'm assuming it's 100%.
Yeah, I think everybody is going and I
think it's important to say this is not
just lifestyle. We're actually getting
at what's causing the problem and
addressing those things. That's what
gives you the best outcomes.
I want to say something about that.
Everybody got very similar lifestyle pro
protocols, right? But beyond that,
because of the very extensive amount of
testing we did, every individual in this
study got a different treatment protocol
based on their specific results. What
toxins did they have? What kind what
level of of insulin uh problem did they
have? Uh what were they exposed to
micotoxins? You know, did they have mold
in their living environment? How
inflamed were they? Uh antio how how
many antioxidants did they what
intensity of antioxidants did they need?
What vascular treatment did they need?
Did they have clotting disorders and so
they needed uh supplementation for that
on and on and on. So each person's
protocol was extensively individualized.
Yeah, great point. So we got some good
ones coming up here. I want to get
through these that um why were the
improvements in mocha similar between
the control and treatment group. So
that's a great question because this
other the CNS vital signs is a much more
sensitive test and was developed
specifically. So it did not have a
learning effect. Just just taking it a
couple times doesn't make you better at
it. So that was really helpful and you
could see that you could see that in the
in the uh control group. But you're
absolutely right. In our first trial, we
saw improvements in mocha in 84% of the
people. And uh this time around, what we
saw was yes, there was an improvement in
the treated one, but there was a lesser,
it was still an improvement. And the
difference was a trend. It was at the
0.154
level. So it didn't reach 0.05. It was
not statistically significantly
different. There was a better in the
control, lesser better in the treatment,
lesser in the control. But they still
have both improved. And I know Kat, you
had one of your patients who told you
why why she thought that was the case.
Well, one of my patients that was in the
delayed treatment cohort was also being
followed at Stanford Neurology for her
cognitive issues, and I didn't find out
until the end of the study that they
were testing her mocha regularly. So, I
think she did the mocha test like seven
or eight times in a nine-month trial.
Well, she was a high IQ person. Even
though her cognition was declining, she
learned how to take that mocha. So,
there was a practice effect. And one of
the things that that I I will need to
tease this out formally, but one of my
theories is I know in my cohort,
everybody had, you know, at least
college education and most of my
patients had advanced degrees. So, we're
talking about higher education, higher
IQ people. and and I think that the
learning effect on the mocha happens
more readily in that kind of profile. Um
so so that was our theory that that
people were learning how to take the
mocha. Um even though we used a
different version. There's three
versions of mocha A, B, and C. And we
used A, B, C, and then we went back to A
at the end. And one of my group B
patients at the end remembered that she
had taken that same version and you know
recalling the animals and things on the
test. So um so I think there was a
learning effect but but let's just you
know say that that was the only one of
our cognitive markers that did not reach
statistically
significance between the two cohorts.
every other marker we did have a a
separation that reached a clear
significance between A and B. I also
think in this trial we had to do mocha
remotely. We used a centralized
neurosychologist trained raider to do it
for all the patients. The
neurosychologist did not know who was in
group A or group B. So they were blinded
to that. But there are problems I think
in doing the mocha online especially
when your hearing is declining and you
know that I feel like the mocha probably
is more accurate if it's done locally
but we tried to standardize it to have
everyone um assessed by the same rider.
Yeah, that's a great point and and I
think it's important to point out when
you are having cognitive decline you
don't forget everything. So you may
remember an old mocha it's that you have
patchiness. So, and especially times
under stress, times with poor, you know,
you do more poorly under stress with
times with poor sleep and on so forth
and so on. So, you may have a problem,
you know, you may ask the same thing
three times at dinner, but at the same
time, you may remember something from
nine months ago. So, it's not that it's
uniformly changed. And so, yes, there
were people that did well. There was a
what looked like a learning effect on
the mocha in this case, but again, there
they they still did better. They just
didn't do so much better that it reached
0.05. 05 it got to 0.154.
Next one here is from Colleen who's
asking what about if someone is in the
13 to 14 range on MOGA. So it's a great
point and many people have seen as you
pass that 16 on the way down lower it
does get tougher. So I think the point
is we've seen people at zeros who got
back their continents and their
discussion and talking. So the point
here it's not that it's yes or no. it's
that as you're going lower and lower,
it's increasingly difficult to address
all the things well enough. So, what
happens is people kind of run out of gas
if they're trying at the lower level.
So, what I would consider for someone in
the 13 to 14 range, and especially if
they haven't had symptoms for too many
years,
please give it 6 to 12 months. Give it a
try. You'll see they should bump up. We
had someone who came in during the
trial, not in the trial, but came in to
Dr. Burke who had a mocha of seven. She
got him up to a 13 and he was clearly
doing better. His symptoms were better.
He was better etc. So it happens but it
is increasingly difficult. This
particular person did have massive
exposure as it turned out to micotoxins.
So um try it for a while but you're
absolutely right. If you're up in the
20s it's much easier to get and sustain
improvement than if you're down in the
low teens. That's correct. And sometimes
when people come in in the moderate
Alzheimer range,
um we can at least stabilize the
decline.
So we might get as much improvement as
we see earlier on, but we can stabilize.
So it's absolutely worth doing. And as
mentioned, stay the course. So don't do
it for a month and say this isn't
helping. Like if you're going to going
to try it, please try it. So it's long
enough. Um excuse me. I have for an
appointment that I was unable to change,
but um I I see we have still lots of
questions coming in. So, I'm hoping
maybe we can repeat this and and just
start by, you know, the ask me anything
format and and and help to have more
people understand what else. And um uh
maybe you want to talk about the uh the
mold testing that we did and how we
incorporated that in in in the protocol
because I think that's something that
not enough people know about.
Yeah. So, let's do this. I know you've
got to run to your appointment and we
we've run out of time here. It's the the
hour is is passed. So, let's set up uh
Ann, would it be okay with you if we set
up a followup where we go through some
of these wonderful questions? There are
lot lots of excellent questions. The
next one here is about PCA. Happy to
discuss that. I would recommend to this
person, contact uh Carrie Rutland, the
the caregiver who who's working with PCA
and Dr. Neil Nathan who's working with
PCA and doing quite a nice job. Uh but
there are, you know, there are dozens
and dozens more here. So, let's set that
up. um if it's okay with with Cad and an
and let's answer some more of these
questions because I do think there
there's so much exciting work to come
out of this and the implications for
patient care and for avoidance of
dementia is huge. So uh we'll end there.
Thanks so much to everybody for the
great questions and we look forward to
talking to you next time. Uh we're we
really are in a new era with this
randomized control trial and
congratulations once again to Dr.
Hathaway and Dr. Tups for the
outstanding outcomes. I just want to say
one thing. There's two types of things
where I have seen uh what seems like a
miracle and that is when someone who's
living in mold moves out of that mold.
Yeah.
That not always but sometimes. Second
thing is sleep apnnea. I've gotten like
three or four calls from spouses who
say, "Oh my gosh, he's back or she's
back when just their sleep apnea was
treated." So, so we do see miracles
sometimes. You know, in general, we
treat everything. We're very aggressive
about that. But, but there are some
miracles.
Great point. And, you know, Steven
Gundry said to me one time that he still
does what he does uh every day of the
week because he's seeing things that 25
years ago he would have considered a
miracle. And he's seeing it again and
again and again with people get better
with their cardiac disease and their
dementia and all these sorts of things.
So, it's a it's an exciting new era. and
we're all seeing these wonderful things.
Kat, I know you got to run.
Say thank you to everybody who joined
us. Thank you so much for your interest
and your support and um we're going to
be trying to put, you know, more
information out because of course we
want everybody to know about these
options and to not think they have no
hope basically. I mean, I just think we
we want people to come away feeling
hopeful.
Absolutely. All right. Any final words,
Ann, that you want to mention?
No. Uh, I'm I'm very grateful to have
been a part of this uh this research and
this whole program and I thank the
people who who are interested enough to
participate today. Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks everybody. All right. Happy
New Year to everyone and thanks again.
We'll see you again.
Thank you. Bye.
Bye.